aren't white people just the worst man
those white people are always getting on
my nerves I hate white people so much
because I'm Sicilian and so we've always
occupied a kind of racially ambiguous
territory and our whole culture hates
white people so you know I'm gonna try
to be on the side of the winners here
it'd be the worst thing I could possibly
be called in this culture there's a
video it's going viral it's called Dear
White parents the trailer for this video
has 980
000 views I have been asked to take all
of my racial expertise and ambiguity and
and bring it to bear on this video take
it away
why the police officer when he killed
the black man why didn't he go to jail
honestly
I don't know how to explain
[Music]
if my parents don't start having these
conversations I think things are going
to get worse why are the police treating
people differently the very opening
question is ridiculous the the kid says
why is it that the black guy or the cop
rather who killed the black guy why
didn't he go to jail cops go to jail in
this country not just for
killing black people even even if some
of the officer-involved killings are
completely Justified but at this point
frankly even looking at someone the
wrong way if you're a white person and
the person you look at is black I mean
cops could lose their jobs they'll be
put on leave this is why people are
leaving the force in huge numbers it's
because they know that one moment goes
wrong or doesn't even go wrong or gets
misrepresented on camera your whole
career is over you might end up behind
bars so the premise is just crazy to
begin with keep going why are the police
treating people different can't they get
in trouble for treating people really
why people haven't been having these
conversations with their children
because they don't have to do you guys
know what it means to have white
privilege when you're not the target of
the Discrimination it's not as visible
to you and that invisibility is a
freedom what do you think it looks like
to see somebody be racist since he
brings up White Privilege don't you
think if White Privilege existed that a
lot of black people pretending to be
white or people from any race Asian
Hispanic Native American pretending to
be white because you'd get a privilege
that way but what's happened in reality
is exactly the opposite all you ever see
in reality is white people pretending to
be black or some other racial minority
you see Rachel dollazole whose Czech in
German and Swedish pretending to be
black for her career and then she gets
exposed and it ruins her life or Jessica
Krug who is a very white Jewish NYU
Professor who pretends to be black for
her career there was another woman whose
Name Escapes me this woman she has the
most Lily white name you ever heard in
your whole life and she pretended to be
black in Indiana and she was a major BLM
activist there gets exposed and ruins
her life even Sachin littlefeather who's
this Native American allegedly who
Marlon Brando sent to accept his Oscar
and to protest the horrible treatment of
the Apache Indians and the Native
Americans he's not Native American at
all her family came out and said no
she's actually just Mexican your name's
Marie Cruz okay who's completely made up
so if there were such a thing as white
privilege you'd see it going in the
opposite direction but actually as far
as racial hierarchies go the worst thing
you can be according to our popular
culture is white it's the only race that
you're allowed to and encouraged to
insult and it's basically the only race
that you're allowed to legally
discriminate against Asians also get
legally discriminated against in college
admissions that might end now with a
Supreme Court case but I don't know it
doesn't sound like privilege to me keep
going
the talk is this conversation that black
parents have with our black children to
prepare them for in essence This Racist
World
[Music]
Justice for him Rihanna Taylor Rihanna
Taylor was a pretty significant figure
in a major drug operation that involved
killing she was she was hanging around
with a ton of of criminals and actually
when the police executed a totally
proper search warrant on her apartment
it was her criminal boyfriend who was
shooting shooting at the cops who
started the whole fight so the Brianna
Taylor thing is just complete complete
nonsense while this organization is
giving you the gift of guilt this
Christmas season if you want to give a
real gift a real good gift to your
friends and loved ones and relatives you
got to check out Black Rifle coffee okay
Black Rifle has all the best Brewing
gear thermoses mugs and apparel designed
for folks who love country and coffee
Black Rifle sources the most exotic
highest grade roasts from around the
globe all coffee roasted here in the US
by veteran-led teams of coffee experts
you can stuff your Christmas stockings
with all the latest roasts from
America's coffee for 10 off with my code
Knowles kwles better yet sign your
Secret Santa up for a coffee Club
subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need them most
it's the gift that keeps on giving Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated they take pride in serving
coffee and culture to people who love
America every purchase you make with
Black Rifle helps support veteran and
first responder causes go to
blackrightfulcoffee.com use promo code
notes for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles
Canada wlas for 10 off Black Rifle
coffee supporting veterans and America's
coffee all right back to the video our
children helping them to understand that
when people treat you differently this
is why and this is how we respond some
white parents with I teach my child to
treat everyone equally to treat everyone
fairly and that's inadequate it is not
enough children
that's the only way what's beautiful and
what's not who gets to be a certain role
and who doesn't if we aren't the ones
teaching them then who or what is what
is racism and what do you think about it
have you ever seen somebody treated
unfairly because of the color of their
skin the talk sounds like it's a yeah
thing whites and Asians in college
admissions a continuous conversation so
certainly seeing that fantastic
what about you have you ever caused
racial harm before
here well this is a hard conversation I
don't want to make my child sad
you don't want to make your child sad
and I don't want my child to die these
are not equivalents is she arguing that
black children or black people generally
are disproportionately at risk of death
because of white criminals is that the
argument or white racist cops or
whatever because that's just complete
fiction that is not borne out in any way
by crime statistics that is that is a
fantasy that is now being used to tell
white kids that they're evil time you
saw someone being treated unfairly
because of racer that you saw things
that seemed not right to you you know I
just did not get it back then and I had
to go back and apologize and say I was
so ignorant to this like I can't believe
I said this everything I was saying was
racist and I didn't even know it talk to
young children about what racism is give
them the language to understanding
because slavery was legal at that point
in time so they can be disrupters even
that even slavery was evil and that's
how you know that there was white
supremacy as though white people in
invented slavery where did the slaves
come from where do you think that
started in the transatlantic slave trade
it was European explorers going to the
west coast of Africa and purchasing
people who had already been enslaved by
Africans and slavery had been practiced
forever and continues to be practiced by
people in North Africa by Muslim slave
Traders this was a major issue at the
founding of the United States by the way
and slavery continues to be practiced
actually everywhere in the world other
than in the west so it's a complete
inversion of reality keep going I think
what's going to help is just talking
about it because right now when we're
having this conversation it helps me
want to stand up pull out a recent
moment in history and talk about what
happened with George Floyd we may not
always know the answer but we'll try and
help you learn and then I want you to
take all the good things that you learn
and try and teach others we do know the
answer we know exactly what happened
with George Floyd George Floyd was a
career Criminal
and a drug addict and he had just
committed a crime and the police were
called to the scene and then George
Floyd took a lethal dose of fentanyl of
drugs and then George Floyd resisted
arrest and then George Floyd continued
to resist arrest for a long period of
time and then there was an
officer-involved killing so obviously
there was a whole trial about that but
we know exactly what happened with
George Floyd and had George Floyd not
done any of the things that led up to
that final altercation with the police
officer George Floyd to be alive today
had he not resisted arrest had he not
taken those drugs had he not committed
the crime had he not committed lots of
other crimes in his life any of those
things had George Floyd not done it
George Floyd would be alive today we
just don't know the answer we do know
the answer we know exactly what the
answer is you don't have to have all the
answers but that doesn't mean we can't
start this time it's time for us to talk
about what happens to people with darker
skin it's time to talk about what do you
believe what type of world do you want
to create
a just world like a just world
which I don't want an anti-racist World
which is very unjust as she is
describing it I want a just world that
is good and with flourishing
and with truth
and with goodness
I don't think I'm going to find that at
Dear White parents that guy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]